I consider Pope Francis to be one of the
most interesting engaged leaders on the
scene today he had a mission when he
became the Pope and that was to bringing
down this power distance between the
Pope and the rest of the Catholic Church
in frankly the rest of the world one of
his first actions that he did was to
step down from the Dyess to be amongst
the people he doesn't put on the robes
he drives a calming car and one of the
things he started doing digitally was to
tweet a lot more be on Facebook through
his various teams but he also started
sitting well with people taking selfies
he would go up to people was like take
selfies with me I think in many ways he
very systematically again decided how he
wanted to engage how he was going to use
these digital tools these social tools
to again break down that power distance
become more connected with his audiences
so that they would be more receptive to
the messages and objectives that he was
trying to spread one of the challenges
that leaders sometimes face is that
there may be resistance to them actually
becoming more engaged so in the case of
Pope Francis when he decided to break
down that power distance step down off
that diet and actually start taking
selfies with people some people felt
like that was cheapening of the position
of the Pope that he wasn't taking it
serious so that he should remain up high
and above it all one of the things that
allows Pope Francis to be such an
engaged leader is that he has this
interesting mix of confidence in himself
and his position but also a tremendous
sense of humility this is something that
has encapsulated everything about his
being from the minute he became a priest
the sense of service and and again a
tremendous humbleness so that it was a
natural thing for him to step off the
dies it's also a very natural thing for
him to extend it into these digital
channels
you